[Music]
hello
my name is matt what's your name okay i
can't hear you
stop so recently i went through a
computer science degree and it was
a rather difficult degree a lot of
people struggled
i struggled some but i have some tips
here
and this time i'm organized so don't
worry it's not going to be a rambly
rampage
about 100 people know what i'm talking
about probably
now what i want to talk about here is
what worked for me
in this particular degree and my way of
getting through it
but first before we get into all that i
want to get all the
my advertisement crap out of the way so
i don't have to think about it or do it
later
first of all if you like computer
science stuff and you like programming
and generally learning
and i don't know just hanging out with
cool people or maybe just me
there's going to be other people on the
channel it's not only me but it's mostly
me because it's my channel
so consider subscribing hit the bell if
you want to see the new updates as they
come along you're going to get to see my
progression because i'm just figuring
this out every day
and hey if you if you don't hit the bell
you might miss my epic blunders that i
have to take down the next day
yeah first version of this all right and
also
if you really really like the stuff
consider maybe
hitting the little patreon link down
below and jumping on
there too and i i do post some behind
the scenes stuff and we chat over there
too
and uh if you don't want to do that but
you want to support some other way
there's other links down there
if you want to if you want to throw me
some bitcoin or whatever you know you're
welcome to do that
and uh you know i'm not i'm not saying
you have to i just feel like i have to
say this or people
won't even ever kind of think anyway
there's also a discord which is
completely free
yeah check all that out okay let's get
into the video
bam that's my transition part one
expectations
and the difficulty knowledge
computer science is one of the hardest
degrees you can get
sure it's probably not as hard as
astrophysics
maybe i don't know maybe maybe it is
depends what school
but it is notably one of the harder
degrees so you're probably
going to have some hard classes and
you're going to be expected to know
things that
are going to be a little beyond you at
times so you've got to
kind of manage those expectations and
what i'm talking about here is
well you're going to have to go through
calculus for me i had to go through
calculus 1 and 2.
calculus 3 was optional if you got
through calculus 3 when
well if you wanted to take calculus
three and got three through it
you would essentially have a math minor
which is pretty cool
i didn't get that but if you really love
the stuff you can get a math minor
but you at least gotta get through
calculus two and you have to pass those
courses
i would advise at least nailing the
basics of calculus down
really well sure they're not that
important if you're going to be a web
developer
or if you're just going to mainly design
or and stuff like that but
honestly if that's your goal computer
science probably isn't for you although
it's it's not like it's a bad choice
computer science
really isn't a bad choice no matter what
you're doing because you can apply
this to so much the world is
increasingly
more computerized so this is all great
stuff to know
so you also are going to be expected to
get through linear algebra
now none of this is too bad if you've
gone through pre-calculus or you felt
like you were decent already at these
topics
uh calculus was pretty hard for me but i
really really loved
linear algebra because i love the 3d
math stuff so i really dove into that
one
but at least get the basics down really
well of these
so aside from those math classes you are
also going to have some stem classes
you're probably either going to be
taking biology chemistry or physics or
some combination of those and you're
going to have labs
and well in my school biology was pretty
easy but it was still a little bit time
consuming
chemistry was very hard and physics was
very hard
but physics could be really useful if
you're
going into like game development you
probably want to do physics
i didn't take physics and i deeply
regret that now
i took i think biology and chemistry and
i didn't really enjoy
either those i think i would have
enjoyed physics more even though it's a
little harder
and takes a little more time the payoff
might be worth it if you
like that sort of thing and also you're
going to have
some english classes some writing
classes and some other electives that
you have to do to fill out credits
alright so let's talk about these
electives a little bit
some of them are really easy you can
kind of nitpick through them
and can pick really easy ones that you
won't have to spend a whole lot of time
on
and that's sort of what i did but also
since you get to choose you can pick
stuff that you're actually actually
interested in
so it is a way to kind of expand and
explore a little bit outside the
computer science realm because maybe
you're really interested in computer
science but there's something in these
electives like psychology that's what it
was for me i really liked
psychology and uh sociology so i got
into those some
but i didn't get very deep in it but it
was enough to kind of explore and you
could apply
some of your computer science stuff to
it later if you want if you just need
a side project and you're doing
something in a class you can talk to
your professor and say
hey i'm a computer science major what
kind of programs can i write or
what kind of data can i exploit or
whatever you know something to apply
your computer science to these electives
and it's kind of a cool thing you can do
and i'll we'll come back to that a
little later because i have some more
stuff i want to say but i don't want to
spend all day on this
first part now the cs courses there's a
lot of them
you're probably going to be taking one
or two every semester
that is decently heavy in the coding
algorithms and whatever else they're
teaching usually they start you out with
a couple of courses on the language then
they get into algorithms and then they
get into
more algorithms and then you kind of get
to pick some
like we had the option of taking
artificial intelligence
parallel computing and there were some
others that i can't
think of some of them are harder than
others and you won't necessarily know it
and often
it depends on the teacher oh yeah i
guess i kind of forgot to mention
[Music]
so yeah just that's that's kind of what
you're getting into
and if you're if it's a pretty
traditional school it's going to be
about four years so you do have time to
space it all out and learn it piece by
piece
and we'll come back to some of that too
all right let's move on
to part two of this and that is a plan
of attack
here is what i did um
pretty much every semester every new
semester or
every mid-semester every semester what i
would do is i would go look at the
what i needed to complete to finish the
degree and i would kind of map it out
i would say okay next semester i'm
taking these courses and that's that
many credits and the one after that i
take those
and i kind of just like graphed it out
like a programmer would i guess it was
just like a tree of things to take every
semester
to graduate and as long as i stuck to it
i would graduate on time
and that way i could kind of be prepared
i'd be i'd be looking at and think okay
next semester
i'm taking these courses so i should
probably get a little head start maybe
do a little research
on what's going to be in the course so i
kind of had that plan of attack going on
and i think that helped a ton
because i was never really that
surprised by what was thrown at me
and i have written down here expect
distractions
so you're gonna have to make a choice
about what's the most
important thing to you like uh
you're gonna have a lot of things you
can do in school you're gonna have
the option to go party with friends
you're gonna have the option to go
study with friends or maybe you'll get a
girlfriend a boyfriend or something like
that
and there's going to be plenty of things
to do that have nothing to do with
studying
or maybe nothing to do with the studying
that you want to do
so you have to make some decisions
about where you want to be in the future
and that's kind of important and it
helps
a lot because if you know what you want
to do in the future
then when it comes time to make a
decision about what you want to do in
the moment
you can kind of have that in the back
your mind and that always helped me
because
sure maybe i'd go hang out for a little
bit but after a while
you know everyone would want to go do
something like i don't know let's go to
a bar
and for me i would you know i would
think about it i'm not a big bar guy
which you know it's fine if you are
but after a drink or two i'm just like i
don't really feel like doing this
anymore
and you know i've had my years of that
it's it's different though because
you know i wasn't as young as the other
kids and they wanted to experience that
stuff i already have already been
through that
i had been in like bands and i've been
in in bars so much that i was kind of
tired of that life
so that that was me but you're gonna
have to find your own thing
it's going to be different for everybody
but in any case there's always going to
be
some distractions maybe you're going to
have a loud person in one of your groups
that's like
really hounding you about something that
just isn't important to you
and you're going to have to figure that
out and figure out how to not let it get
to you and not let it
basically waste your time because hey if
you want to study computer science and
you want to do really well
at learning whatever language it is and
just really nailing these algorithms
that's going to take a lot of your time
and you're going to have to kind of like
push other things to the to the back
burner
and you know if you kind of already know
you want to do that
you're going to have a much easier time
explaining it in the
in the moment to people that don't
really get why you're
i don't know maybe the way you are or
something i don't know because like for
me
i had labs like i had this biology lab
and it was
or i guess it was chemistry lab that i'm
thinking of here it was
it was grueling it was like two hours of
just like you know mixing stuff and
doing experiments filling out paper
and rinse repeat and and doing these
labs and they
like by the end of it i would feel like
i was falling asleep i would just be
like i'm so tired
i don't want to do this anymore makes
the thing okay
yeah right they have a little reaction
or you could spend a lot of time there
like
really toying around with things and
really learning the stuff even deeper
and really understanding that reactions
or whatever
and for me it wasn't like that i just
kind of i just kind of won it and got
through it because
it was an aside for me and it was kind
of cool to experience
and sure i did as well as i could in the
moment but when it came time to be like
oh there's there's extra stuff you could
stay and do
i was like no i gotta go uh work on my
software
so see you later kind of thing you know
or if people
after the lab were like hey let's go get
lunch and i knew that
thing i really need to go study i'd be
like
uh i'd say something like okay but i
can't stay for long or something or i'll
just get it to go or you know
i would i would have to make decisions
like that all right and find a place
find a place where you know you can
study where no one's going to distract
you
this is really important this is
probably the most important thing to be
honest because
i think it's just the way the human mind
is if we know we're going to be
interrupted
if we know youtube is available
we can't focus on the problems that are
right
like there and needs solved
and that we want to solve but there's
something fun and easy to do
it's where like nobody really knows you
too well
or nobody's going to interrupt you or
maybe where you don't have internet and
you only have
your resources for your stuff that was
big for me i would often go to like
the top of the library or there was a
couple floors certain spots
in the library and i would just turn my
phone off for like an hour or two
and i would turn the internet off on my
computer or sometimes i would turn it on
and download
like the pdf or resources i need and
then i would turn it off
and only work on the thing i was working
on
or i would download the music i wanted
to listen to and then i would turn the
internet off
and for me obviously i'm on youtube and
i watched it i've always watched youtube
i've always tried to find
tutorials in fact so i started this
channel is because
i couldn't find the tutorials for the
stuff i was looking for
so i decided i was going to make them
myself and here we are now
so hopefully this helps so find
that little place you can go and really
actually get some thinking and work done
and uh and don't overdo it you know just
stay there for an hour or two
see if you can make some strides i
remember i was really struggling in this
one it was like a numbers class
uh part of the math curriculum and it
was really hard
but i i remember just just being like
i'm just getting away and i'm taking
this book and i'm studying this until i
get it and it and i got it and it felt
so great to just be like yes
it clicked stay organized too that's
that's on here too but i think it's all
kind of
wraps around there with the staying
organized i tried a lot of different
things for staying organized because a
lot of the traditional methods don't
work for me
like putting things on a google calendar
doesn't work for me for some reason i
can't i can't keep up with that
i guess what bothers me about it is i
have to like
open up a web page wait for it to load
then if i'm somewhere with no internet i
i can't look at my calendar and it was
just there was always something with all
these
things that were offered so i'll show
you
what i did i used a piece of software
i'm gonna pull up here and show you i
actually wrote it so
what i did is i wrote my own
organization software doing a little
little switching over we're gonna look
at github so i got
bored in one of my classes or i was
trying to schedule stuff and
and one day i was just like okay i'm
just gonna write a little command line
program
for writing this stuff so here we go
there it is
and i wrote this it's called deadline
spelled with weird numbers
and all it is is just a little linux
terminal program
build it and run it it just if you have
c plus plus it'll it'll run it doesn't
need anything else
and you can add tasks and remove tasks c
and sort
and then there's save and quit so all
this this all this does is
anytime you get an assignment you just
hit add task and it asks you when it's
due
so that's that's it and well this is all
about
priority it shows you the thing that's
due the soonest
so if you just work on that you'll be
fine
so anytime you don't know what to do you
can just
uh run this program and and look at your
the next thing that's due
so like the top of the list which says
priority task it's all about doing the
priority task the thing that's due next
and then you can mark it complete with
uh remove task
so once you're done with it you'll see
the next one and the priority
and every time you get assigned
something with a due date you just hit
add task this works really well for
school
because things have due dates like if i
put this stuff on a calendar it was
really hard for me to like
look at the calendar some things or do a
month later
and i would have to like you know scroll
from month to month or week to week
and try to figure out okay what should i
be working on with this thing
it was like this one's due the soonest
work on that
and i would do that and then when it's
finished it would be like okay this
one's due next
work on that and before you know it i'd
have everything done and then i go to my
next class get new tests do buy whatever
prioritization program for busy students
with many assignments and deadlines
never forget to do something again this
helped me a ton so
i don't know maybe you'll like it i'll
leave a link down below it's uh
it's nothing super super special but it
was also cool because it was like this
is a real world
thing that i could find useful
that i can write as like a side project
and you know helped me advance my c
plus a little bit because also this you
know it
i started using the chrono library a
little bit which no they didn't really
teach so
if you want to learn you have to figure
that out on your own and it just keeps
track of the time you know
and uh automatically manages all that
all you got to do is do this add and
remove
just add a task anytime you get one and
that that's basically it
all right well enough about that for now
but please
if you like it go give it a star i would
appreciate that
or if you use it and see something
broken or you don't like something about
it
feel free to work on it it's open source
you can work on it all you want
all right part three getting through the
day today
you know i don't know if i really need
to say much more about this i kind of
really already touched on that with the
uh the find a place and staying
organized and you
and using programs like deadline task
priority
if a traditional calendar doesn't work
for you i guess the big
thing is yeah you just do have to take
it day by day
because if you try to like do everything
at once you're gonna be overwhelmed
if you get um i don't know if you get
really
unmotivated and just on one day
try to just take some small steps you
know they're i'm sure you guys have
probably heard videos about stuff like
this before like the five minute rule
or the two minute rule just do it for
two or five minutes and see where it
goes from there i i kind of did stuff
like that and it helped me
get from day to day because there were a
lot of days where i was just like i
i've been working a lot i don't feel
like it anymore
and then i would kind of uh you know
i'd go take a nap or i'd go exercise or
something
and then i'd be like all right i'm just
going to work on this this thing that i
know i have to do for two minutes or
sometimes
when i didn't want to do anything this
actually really helped me a lot
because i would i would just go to my
little terminal and
slash deadline and it would open up my
little piece of software here
and i would see the thing at the top and
i was like okay i'll just work on that
for a little bit and before you know it
it was done
and things like that would happen but
usually you know this
screenshot says edit video but often
this would say something like
algorithms or homework which was
incredibly hard
and it would take hours and hours to do
but as long as i kept like
re-looking at it looking at the next
question just being like
let me just get this done and also
sometimes this day-to-day and
week-to-week thing
sometimes you're going to have
assignments that are due and things that
need done
that you don't have done you don't have
a way of getting them done because you
don't know the answer
and just try your best
it's better to have something to turn in
than nothing at all
even if you for some reason get a bad
grade on it because maybe you didn't
know how to do it very well
that's better than not turning in
anything at all and it's also better
than cheating
don't cheat as much as you can avoid it
anyway
i will admit that there were times that
i went to
some other students i was like and i was
like hey i don't know how to do this
i've been trying
do you know how to do this can you show
me and sometimes they would be like i
don't feel like showing you
here's the answer and i'd be like i'll
write it down but i still want to figure
it out so that happened because
you know sometimes just kind of knowing
what you want to get to
can help you figure out the steps a
little bit so things like that happen
but don't blatantly cheat even if you do
somehow get the answer
try to figure out the steps to get to
that answer is actually really important
because that's that's something later in
life that's also really important
too because uh when you're you know
you're actually doing something when
you're actually at a job
you need to know the steps you're gonna
have to train other people
and stuff like that if you don't know
how to do it there's gonna be times that
you look like a fool
so it's best to just be like hey i want
to know the steps
in any case
all right well that's it for this video
i really hope this helps somebody
don't forget to hit all those buttons
and stuff i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna blurb it all again but if
this helps you
you know consider uh giving back a
little bit and maybe that's just leaving
a comment with your story
or something like that or just saying
thanks or giving someone else some
encouragement
alright i'll see you guys in the next
video math code tech tutorials
over and out peace
[Music]
you